[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab - beauty
science chemistry PhD and youtuber with
over a hundred thousand subscribers I
was told that real youtubers do a Q&A
when they reach a master a number of
subscribers so here it is I asked you to
submit questions on YouTube Instagram
and Facebook I got a lot of replies too
many to do in one video and so I tried
to group together similar questions and
really just cover the common ones in the
video I'm going to start with questions
about me and lab life and beauty science
and then move on to some specific beauty
and skincare questions in a rapid-fire
sort of way I did get a lot of questions
on how to use sunscreens which I've
actually answered before in some of my
previous videos I'm planning to make
more videos about sunscreen even though
most of us probably aren't getting much
Sun due to social distancing but I've
linked my previous video on how to wear
makeup and sunscreen together in the
video description I did this as a get
ready with me so there's something
interesting to look at while I answer
these questions but I'm not very good at
makeup so chances are I've skipped
something or I had to fix it afterwards
if you like this sort of science heavy
beauty content please give me a thumbs
up subscribe to my channel and you can
click the notification bell so you don't
miss any videos I'm starting with a
moisturizer since I'm not planning to go
outside today and my house is really
shady plus it's really cloudy and rainy
today so where do I live I live in
Sydney Australia I was originally born
in Hong Kong and I moved here when I was
2 years old
why is your channel called lab muffin
beauty science so I wanted to start a
blog back in 2011 but I know that I
personally tend to have this habit of
not taking initiative and not doing
things and giving myself excuses not to
do things so I spent a long time trying
to decide on a name and then I realized
I was just never going to pick one so I
just picked a name and decided I would
just stop blogging and I could change
the name later but then that never
happened
is YouTube Instagram your full-time
career or do you have another job and if
so how do you balance your job and your
blog I do almost full-time now but I do
still have another job
I teach senior high school chemistry at
a tutoring college these are classes of
about 15 students I'm also writing an
online textbook for high school
chemistry for a long time I was actually
working full time as the chemistry
coordinator for this tutor in college
but as my blog ramped up I had to step
down because it was just way too much
for me during that time our state New
South Wales was also switching
syllabuses so me and my team had to
rewrite all of the textbooks that all
the teachers were teaching off so it was
really full-on and so basically to
balance it I just had no personal life
um how else I managed to balance it I
planned everything meticulously so I was
working my full-time job every Tuesday
to Saturday and so on Saturdays I would
Michiko lessly plan out what I was going
to do on Sunday and Monday like to the
hour I had to do lists yes so that
really helped
what would I be doing if I wasn't a
blogger I actually really loved my
full-time job it was really challenging
but also really rewarding and I
especially liked it because I was
working with a really cool bunch of
people everyone was really passionate
and talented at educating um so yeah it
was it was sad to leave I haven't really
left
I still go in all the time and I'm still
teaching there obviously so it's really
good that I have a lot more time now but
as a lot of you have probably discovered
lately working from home is actually
pretty lonely you don't have anyone to
bounce ideas off you don't have people
to get a second opinion off very easily
so the next set of questions is a whole
bunch of questions about me and science
what did my educational path look like
what drew me to chemistry did I always
know that I wanted to be in science what
was my PhD thesis on what was my note
what was my motivation to do a PhD what
do I currently research and why did you
leave academia so first off I'm no
longer in academia so that is affiliated
with a university so I don't currently
do research I do think it's important to
acknowledge though that research
scientists aren't the only real
scientists I think that sentiment comes
from a toxic part of academia so my
educational path I really loved
chemistry in high school but I also
really enjoyed arts I I did extension to
English which is where you get to do a
major work so I did performance poetry I
did modern history my schedule was sort
of like a 50:50 Arts and Science split
I wasn't really sure what I was going to
do so um I Ashley J chemistry Olympiad
when I was in high school and so there
was an option where I could skip some of
first year chemistry so being a bit lazy
I decided to do combined science and law
I felt like that was like a good
combination of science and arts yeah so
in Australia you have to pick your
degree right out of high school as
you're going into university
so hasn't as a 17 year old I really had
no idea what was going what I was going
to do so I kind of just yeah picked a
picked a degree based on what my friends
were doing what seemed good at the time
based on my very limited life knowledge
which i think is probably not the best
decision or probably just not the best
set of circumstances to make such a big
decision under so in Australia at the
time at the end of third year uni you
get to pick whether or not you do an
honest you so this is like a research
year and it's a pretty easy decision
honestly so honours counts as like a
masters so if you want to progress to do
a PhD you only need to use one year plus
you get extra letters at the end of your
degree plus you just defer the rest of
your study for a single year so that was
an easy decision I decided to pick I
decided to do a research project at the
time I was also working in a law firm as
a paralegal
and I discovered that I really loved
doing that project and I really hated
working in corporate law so I decided to
do a PhD Sanchez with my undergrad
subjects I did chemistry pharmacology
and physiology I also did a bit of
psychology and maths in first year my
PhD project was on cyclic peptides these
have lots of applications of medicinal
chemistry and in supramolecular
chemistry which is the chemistry of how
different substances interact without
actually undergoing a chemical reaction
the problem with cyclic peptides is that
it's quite hard to make them so my
project was on making them and then
exploring the applications so at the end
of my PhD I again was in the position
where I didn't know what I was going to
do with my life so usually I drew this
step before I drew blush but because I'm
distracted by the questions I forgot but
basically I'm using a heavier foundation
to cover up some of my some of the
blemishes that are showing up through
foundation so yeah I wasn't really sure
what I was going to do with my life
a lot of my peers work going into
patient law or consulting or going on to
do a medical degree so if you want to
continue in academia you can do a
postdoc my boyfriend at the time except
a1 in Switzerland and so I moved there
with him I knew I didn't personally want
to stay in academia so my supervisor
told me there was no point during a
postdoc there was also a lab accident in
my final year of my PhD and that really
put me off staying in academia and
staying in research I actually had a bit
of PTSD from that as well when I was
studying my PhD I had the opportunity to
do quite a bit of teaching so I was
taking 30 tutorials and I was teaching
in labs and I really really loved that
the problem is there's not that many
teaching opportunities in academia and
the alternative is teaching in high
school which I didn't think I
as a small asian girl would be able to
do very well
some of my friends at the time we're
tutoring at a tutor in college and they
were saying it was really awesome and so
I applied for that and then eventually
they asked me to stay on full-time and
the online textbook company grew out of
that company so that's how I got brought
on board to do the chemistry part so how
old are you so from my relatively long
path you can probably guess that I am in
my 30s I am turning 33 this July I
graduated high school in 2004 I was
quite young for my year and I went
straight through my undergrad and my PhD
so I actually finished my PhD at 25 what
made me start a YouTube channel so like
I said I did a lot of teaching and as I
was teaching I found myself at the
whiteboard drawing lots of stuff and
moving my arms a lot and that really
highlighted the limitations of trying to
just blog so just having text and images
I think text isn't always the best way
to communicate a complex concept in as
simple away as possible and having a
video means that I can do a lot more
stuff I can use a lot more tools to try
to explain things to people and I found
that doing videos has actually allowed
me to reach a very different audience
which is great
what made me so passionate about
skincare and beauty so when I started my
blog back in 2011 I was really annoyed
at the pseudoscience that was around
especially all the marketing myths and I
was really struck by the lack of people
addressing these myths in an accessible
way so one of the career options I was
looking at when I was doing my PhD with
science communications unfortunately a
lot of people in science communication
especially male scientists tend to
dismiss Beauty as something that's not
worth their time something that's a lost
cause which i think is really just a bit
of misogyny I think it comes from the
fact that it is a very female heavy area
and women's interests have always just
been regarded as more frivolous and less
serious than male pursuits
[Music]
even now when I talk to other science
communicators I often get comments from
men telling me that I should switch to
something else so I'll put a couple up
on the screen and you can see them so
for example this guy thinks I should
switch to talking about quantum
computing from a science communication
perspective I saw that many women are
interested in it and it's a really good
chance to get people interested in
science I found that the best way to get
people interested in science is to tell
them the science behind something that
they're already interested in something
that's relevant to their everyday life
which quantum computing for most people
just is not what got me into skincare
well I've always had kind of troublesome
skin and I think that's the reason most
people get into skincare what have I
changed my mind about half of the things
I've actually researched and F to be
honest the further I've gotten into
researching the science behind beauty
products the more I've realized that my
gut feelings are not a good guide as to
what the science is on anything so
fragrance and skincare I used to think
it was evil now I am a lot less adamant
about that alcohol and skincare I also
used to think that was evil jar
packaging um even aluminium I used to
think there was something behind the
fears about aluminium but then I
realised it was really quiet unfounded
on a less scientific note my
relationship with my appearance has
changed a lot I've always been pretty
insecure about my looks but as I've
gotten older the less I give a toss
which part about my job is my favorite
in terms of vlogging I love most things
so I really love researching and finding
out about the real science behind how
stuff works I really enjoyed the
creative side of writing and making
diagrams making animations I think the
thing I like the least is definitely
replying to emails and replying to
individual emails is fine it's just when
there's a massive volume of them and I
do spend hours each week replying to
emails it's just never-ending
any advice with people wanting to get
into chemistry I think the biggest piece
of advice that most Australian chemistry
graduates give is check what the job
opportunities actually are when you
leave
try to us someone relatively impartial
ask multiple people who are relatively
impartial because when you're applying
for a university degree most of them
just want you to do that degree it
worked out well for them and so they
have a massive bias advice with people
who want to understand chemistry but are
really bad at school um I think no one
is really truly bad at chemistry I think
most people will have just had bad
teachers or just teachers whose job
didn't work for them so I think it's
really a matter of finding a teacher
whose style works for your learning
style there are some really good free
online resources now for learning
chemistry so things like casera youtube
series like crash course I'll put a few
links in the description how do you like
living in Australia best and worst parts
so I think the best part is almost
definitely the fantastic weather we also
have a relatively nice lifestyle we have
universal health care for example and
really good public transport in a lot of
places but I do think we have it pretty
good here so a lot of people are
complacent and I think with recent
disasters like the bush fires the floods
and now Cove in nineteen the cracks are
starting to show so things like how we
have a very casual based workforce our
reliance on cheap under-the-table
imported labor and decreased funding for
public services like our National
Broadband Network our internet is one of
the worst in the world and increasing
privatization of healthcare so other
terrible things about Australia the
shipping prices are awful and generic
drugstore brands are really expensive
things like Revlon L'Oreal Maybelline
they are at like the twenty thirty
dollar mark you
[Music]
am I going to start my own skincare or
nail polish brand I've definitely
thought about it but I just haven't
really got a compelling idea yet so
we'll see which of my videos am I most
proud of so far I'm really proud of my
alcohol in skincare collaboration with
Stephen I put a lot of effort into the
editing it probably doesn't look worth
it but it's took me hours and hours and
it took us a really long time for the
research and I'm really proud of how
rigorously we did it
why haven't my made a video about insert
topic a lot of people ask how long does
it take me to make a video so I put
these questions together because the
second question answers the first
question my videos generally aren't very
easy to make
[Music]
I have really high standards possibly
impractically high standards for the
information I put out I feel like since
I'm a scientist and I put myself out as
a scientist in the public arena I'm
responsible for putting out
scientifically rigorous information and
I generally just have that straight aged
student mentality I want to put
information out there that I can
confidently stand by and what that means
is hours and hours of reading and
literature searches
I'm always fact checking and rechecking
and rechecking continuously and I'm only
one person with 24 hours in a day and so
even with all of this I still miss stuff
and get stuff wrong so the time required
for a video can be upwards of 100 hours
so for example for the alcohol video
Steven and I actually started planning
this in 2016 and it is now 2020 if it's
a video with just basic chemistry
information like my five minute crafts
critique then there's still a tiny bit
of fact-checking but I can pump that out
a lot faster I think that one took me
eight to ten hours also I'm not very
good at video editing um what is my
favorite snack I love garlic dip so this
is tomb which is the garlic dip that's
basically 60% oil and 40% garlic it is
delicious my breath smells awful I am
eating the crap out of it while we're
doing social distancing any tips for
skin care during lockdown
[Music]
um I think my only real tip is if it
stresses you out don't do it if it helps
you relax do it if you've lost all of
your skincare and makeup which items
would you repurchase first so obviously
one of the first things would be a
sunscreen my favorite is ultra suitable
stalee moisturizer I also would want a
cleanser and a moisturizer
I think the basics are by far the most
important products in a routine
so for cleanser I want something gentle
for a moisturizer I probably just want
something with glycerin so the makeup I
definitely need would be concealer eye
liner and a lipstick that can double up
his blush
which ingredients have made the most
difference for your skin I would say
threatenin which is a prescription of
vitamin A vitamin C and lactic acids
[Music]
all right some quickfire skincare and
beauty questions why don't I use SPF 100
since it's better than SPF 50
we don't have SPF 100 in Australia our
highest is SPF 50 plus other reasons
would be it doesn't feel good and if you
don't wear enough of any sunscreen you
won't get the specified protection so if
you put on an adequate amount of SPF 50
plus it might actually work better than
a tiny tiny bit of SPF 100 what age
should you start to incorporate retinol
into your skin routine if you're after
anti-aging or anti acne benefits any age
will do so you can start it in your 20s
if you're using up for acne you can even
start it in your teens how do we know if
a claimed SPF is real there isn't really
any way
[Music]
at the moment the only real way is to
conduct a clinical task where 10
volunteers and use it on their skin is
there really a difference between types
of ingredients like ceramide in
different products um it really depends
on the ingredient with with most
ingredients you can get impurities that
are different based on who you've bought
that ingredient off for things like
glycerin where it's only one type of
molecule or water then there generally
isn't any difference with ceramides
there are different types of ceramide so
if it just says ceramide you don't know
which one it is so there's like Sarah my
1 3 if it's highly ironic acid there's
tons and tons of different molecular
weights that are all called hyaluronic
acid so yeah depends is talc really
unsafe in skincare
um so the main thing that's wrong attack
is that it can have asbestos impurities
and asbestos is mostly bad if you inhale
it
cosmetic manufacturers are meant to
check what the impurities are in talc
and make sure it's asbestos free um how
do you protect your scalp from UV I
would recommend a hat I think that is
the most practical way is it better to
use the static lines over micellar water
for the second step of the double
cleanse it really depends on your skin
depends on the cleanses depends on the
micellar water
[Music]
can topical hyaluronic acid replaced the
hyaluronic acid in the lower layers of
your skin know so if by low layers you
mean the dermis which is pretty low it
can't get down that far in general
hyaluronic acid is really really big it
can't get through deeper into your skin
than like the very top layers one of my
thoughts on X product I try not to
review products that I haven't
personally tried because I think there's
just so much in the formulation you just
cannot work out how a product will work
just from looking at the ingredients
list so if I don't tell you my thoughts
on a particular product it's probably
cuz I haven't tried it generally if I
try to product enough I will review it I
enzyme exfoliants effective I have an
exfoliation guide which talks about
enzyme exfoliant yes they are effective
or they can be effective they tend to
only really exfoliate the very surface
layers of your skin they are really good
for irritated skin how can I stop
physical sunscreen from peeling I
recommend just patting it on also check
the compatibility of whatever you're
putting on underneath it the less stuff
you put underneath a physical sunscreen
or any product the less likely that
there is that there'll be an
incompatibility which makes it pill I've
also heard that sometimes if you put it
on fast enough then the film doesn't dry
as you're trying to work it around your
skin and anything else you put on top
again Pat it on and try not to disturb
the film too much what ingredients do
you look for in a moisturizer it really
depends on your skin in my ebook the lab
muffin guide to basic skincare I talked
about how to pick one that fits your
skin if you're asking about my personal
skin I love glycerin
[Music]
there's also an ingredient that I've
just momentarily blanked out on the name
of um which is in a bunch of sunscreens
and it makes them feel amazing I will
look up that name and put it on the
screen as well as my skincare guide I
also have a whole bunch of blog posts on
moisturizer which you can look at as
well if you go to the search bar on my
blog you can find those which skincare
supplements would I recommend
so from a scientific perspective all
supplements are unnecessary unless you
are actually deficient in a particular
nutrient so for example most people are
deficient in vitamin D in winter in most
countries so I wouldn't recommend any
skincare supplements I think a balanced
diet is much better so other skin
related supplements that if you're
deficient in can make your skin bad
vitamin B omega-3 yeah talk to a doctor
if you think you might be deficient in
one of these do moisturizing products
need to be sealed in with oil No
there are studies where they just use
glycerin and that was fine without
anything on top moisturizing products
might work more efficiently if you do
put oil on top though so try it out on
your skin what doesn't mean when skin
doesn't need to breathe it means skin
does not need oxygen from the air so
there's no biological reason why you
need to make sure your skin has enough
exposure to air why do your older
sunscreen filters irritate skin more and
give more allergic reactions than your
ones basically because new ones are
specifically designed with not
irritating and not giving allergic
reactions in mind so new ones tend to be
bigger which means they don't go into
skin as easily and so they can't get
into the Living layers and cause
irritation allergic reactions can you
use a chaise and BHA with retinol it
depends on your skin they might be too
irritating but there's no rule that you
cannot are there specific ingredients
that close your pores and give you acne
it depends on your skin every one is
slightly different the same ingredient
formulated in two different products
will have a different effect
so check out micromanage Anisa tea video
if you want more information about that
won't telomeres shorten with rationale
your skin has cells where they've killed
me is don't shorten which means that you
will not exfoliate and run out of skin
or you won't use rationale and run out
of skin at any point within your
lifetime so that is it I think my face
is done it is very possible that I've
forgotten to do something
since I'm not good enough that make up
to do two things at once I hoped you
liked this video if you did give it a
thumbs up you can also subscribe to my
channel for more videos where I talk
about the science behind beauty products
you can follow me on Instagram and you
can check out my blog for more as well
please don't yell at my makeup technique
or perhaps yell at me gently I'm clearly
not the most experienced at drawing
makeup so if you have any tips for me
leave them in the comments please don't
yell at me Larry I will see you next
time
you